A wood router, is a necessary shop tool, but
they can be awkward to work with when you
have to freehand your projects. There's a
better way, and it doesn't have to be expensive.
In this project, we're turning any ordinary
table, into a multipurpose work bench, with
a built-in, flush mount router station.
For this project, we're gonna need a wood
router. I found this one, on my local classifieds.
And we're gonna need a square foot of plexiglass
or acrylic like this. This piece is 1/4" thick,
it's crystal clear, and only cost $5.00 from
a local plastics company. Let's get started
by choosing a good spot on the table, then
tracing the edges of the square with a pencil,
or a pen. You can see I've put a 1/2" straight
bit into the chuck of this router, and now
if we measure from the edge of the blade,
to the side of the sub-base, the distance
is 2-5/8". I used that measurement to cut
a piece of wood that matches perfectly flush
with the side. Ok, now we can go ahead and
use our piece of wood as a measuring tool,
to draw a border around the outside of the
square. Next, we'll need to draw an inner
square, about 1-1/4" smaller than the first
one. I decided to angle the corners, for aesthetics,
and support, and now all the markings and
measurements look like this.
Alright, it's time to cut ourselves a hole.
Let's start by using a large drill bit to
make holes on the inner sides of the angled
lines. This way, we can insert the jigsaw
blade and begin cutting right away. The goal
here is to cut each line as straight as possible,
and when we make it back to the starting point,
the center piece should fall right out. Now
we still need this plastic plate, to sink
down flush with the top of the table. And
we'll be able to do that with the help of
8 concrete paving stones. The concrete squares
need to line up perfectly with the outside
edges of the outer square, and when they're
all aligned, it's time for the action.
Let's use the plastic plate, to gauge the cutting
depth. And we can do that by adjusting the
height of the sub-base, until the tip of the
bit, is flush with the top of the plate. Now
when we turn on the router, and rest the base
flat on the table, it should be cutting down
to the exact depth of the plastic mounting
plate. You can see that as we move along in
a clockwise direction, the concrete blocks
prevent the side of the router from going
out of bounds. This helps keep the cuts clean
and straight, and in-line with the markings
we made around the plate. Now that we've cut
the outer boundary, we can freehand the router
back and forth, until the inner bits are profiled
down as well, then finish up, by sanding the
new surface smooth. Now if you look at the
corners, you might notice they're a bit rounded,
so let's just grind a little bit of plastic
off the corners of the plate, to match the
curves. And now you can see that now the plate
will drop straight in, and sit flush with
the top of the table.
Ok, it's time to mount the plate, to the router
base.
There are 3 screws holding the base plate
on, and when those are removed, it comes off
very easily. If we center it on our square,
we can use it as a template, to mark the position
of the screw holes, then drill them out with
a 7/32" drill bit. Now I tried taking a little
off the top with a 3/8" bit, and ended up
with a countersink effect. You can see that
when the screws are set back in, they sit
flush with the top, but don't catch on anything
sliding over them. The next step is to drill
a hole in the center with a 1-1/2" Forstner
bit, then make two more holes, in line with
the center using a 7/8" bit. These two holes
will give us handles to remove, and replace
the router at will. Let's go ahead and remove
the protective paper now, then line the plate
up on the router where the sub-base used to
sit. The original screws can be returned,
to secure the new plate in place, and you
can see the plastic is more than strong enough
to support the weight of the router. I added
a couple of beams underneath to re-enforce
the table top, and prevent it from sagging
over time. For a nice finishing touch, let's
try cutting a piece of black construction
paper, to make a decorative lining for our
new router station. At this point, our router
table is completely finished, and ready for
operation. For our first project, why don't
we try routing the edges of our new table
with this 3/4" beading bit. You'll notice
that even with the custom mounting plate,
the router is still completely portable, for
any projects you need to router by hand. The
extra surface area of the plate, actually
keeps the unit more stable, and helps ensure
the cut lines are as straight as they can
be. Now just for fun, I gave my table a paint
job so when the router sets in place, the
whole thing has got a clean professional look
to it. I also rigged up a switch box for electrical
power, that will give us the option of turning
on a backlight, and starting up the router
from a safer distance. Now, one of the things
I like best about this design, is that the
bit can be fully retracted when we don't need
it. This means we still have full access to
the entire work table. And that can be very
helpful for projects like the rocket rifle
that we made in a previous project. And because
the system is so easy to remove and replace,
changing out router bits is simple as well.
Well now you know, how to add a professional
looking, flush mount router station, to any
work table. So go ahead and make a picture
frame, put finishing touches on experimental
projects, or makes some puzzles for entertaining
friends, because now you can. That's it for
now. If you liked this project, perhaps you'll
like some of my others. Check them out at
www.thekingofrandom.com